the FBI has said that more pipe bombs
may be out there but false alarms have
led to confusion
New York City's Time Warner Center was
partially evacuated again last night
after two unattended packages were found
JEP pegasi is outside FBI headquarters
in Washington Jeff good morning good
morning investigators determined that
the incident at the Time Warner Center
was a false alarm it is not unusual at
all to have incidents like that given
the last several days of increased
police activity and suspicious packages
all of which have given the FBI plenty
of leads to follow this has to be taken
with the utmost seriousness earlier
Thursday investigators insisted their
mission is clear as far as a hoax device
we're not treating it that way packages
are being examined at the FBI's high
tech bomb laboratory in Quantico
Virginia
where they will rely in part on research
done in facilities like this one
so tape is very good at retaining
fingerprints tape tape is where the ATF
studies homemade explosives don't take
it to these instruments right away you
use your eyes first and the lab of
University of Rhode Island professor
Jimmy Oxley which has exploded more than
100 pipe bombs to gauge the blast effect
in a lot of cases you see the
perpetrator enhance the primary
fragments either by taping nails or
screws to the outside putting them
inside with it it's juggler vane or any
other important part of your body could
kill you but former ATF agent David
Chapman says there are still many
unanswered questions now we have to
figure out like could it have functioned
why didn't it how were the parts
assembled and you know there are clues
in there the targets of this week's
attempted mail bombings called them a
warning sign these papers being mailed
they might wake everybody and my
business up a little bit and declared a
new era of American politics the
potential for violence is somehow
entered our political in
that's disturbing there has been a pause
in the discovery of these suspicious
packages over the last 24 hours
investigators have been concerned that
there could be another one out there
somewhere that could potentially injure
or kill still they are asking the public
to remain vigilant Gail yeah thora teas
are all over thank you very much Jeff